definitely the packers in prime time
five times despite the unsettled aaron
rodgers situation and you know what it
ended up being a smart move you know why
chris why
they got blake blake bortles on the team
now your second favorite quarterback
yes that's right baby all their troubles
are answered it really doesn't matter if
rogers comes back now it really doesn't
they don't really need him he's
expendable you know bortles is there
it's all said and done so hey i mean all
serious they needed a guy i mean as we
know for for you know otas and things
like that you know that's that's that's
what they're worried about they need to
arm a guy that's like a little bit of a
professional jordan loves raw young they
need somebody that can run practice and
do those type of things you know so
bortles has a little history with
nathaniel hackett the offensive
coordinator there and that's why that's
done um but
uh yes i got a little chuckle and giggle
out of that yesterday too
i'd love to see the first text message
aaron rodgers sent
after hearing that blake bortles had
signed i mean if this guy calls brian
gudykoon's jerry krause what the hell
does he call blake bortles maybe he
calls him blake bortles
so uh
but they but they need the arm they need
the body they do they this is in
anticipation of the upcoming otas and
only had two quarterbacks on the roster
anyway they need more than blake bortles
they're going to need to add at least
one other guy to get through all the
reps of the 90-man roster in training
camp and otas and they may need to add a
second one if aaron rodgers isn't going
to be there
this is not the the end this is the
beginning of the quarterbacks the green
bay packers may be adding but everything
the packers do at this point from a
quarterback standpoint will generate
news more news yesterday from john [ __ ]
who last week was on cbs sports radio
explaining that he believes the aaron
rodgers situation is fixable james jones
former teammate of rogers as well was on
nfl network explaining that the
situation is fixable my interpretation
of it very simple these guys talk to
rogers
and
unless they are talking publicly about
the things they've talked to rogers
about with his express or implied
permission he risks joining me on the
aaron rodgers
it list
which is yeah most i like that the atlas
so
so uh
so [ __ ] was back talking yesterday he
was on nfl network
and reiterating his belief that the
situation is fixable and pointing out
one of the things we said doesn't matter
how much you're paying him under a new
contract it's the structure it's the
guarantee it's the knowledge that you're
going to be there that's the key you can
pay them 50 million a year if you only
have them for one year if you still have
that structure where you can say after
one year see you later we're trading you
problem isn't solved problems only
solved if the packers have no practical
ability to cut him trade him or cut him
they can't do it and [ __ ] bottom line i
we're friends we talk we played 10 years
together and i think it's fixable and
there's no way in hell he is doing that
without aaron rodgers wanting him to do
it he may not realize that aaron rodgers
wants him to do it but aaron rodgers
clearly and this is one of the
byproducts of being so smart you're
viewed as somebody who is smart enough
to know how if you're not going to speak
directly to get your message out through
surrogates sure now for some reason [ __ ]
didn't appreciate that i couched it in a
factual manner which is exactly what it
was and what it is and i think he wants
to beat me up chris so i may need your
help i don't know though i don't know
six foot five quarterback versus a
fullback i'm probably putting my money
on the fullback i will remember this
mike florio and i will find you
what the hell
as i said if i end up if i end up dead
search the trunk of coon's car please uh
chris i may need your help i made i mean
need you and phil in fact i pro phil's
thicker than you i'd probably rather
have phil watching my back than you when
john [ __ ] comes looking for me hey screw
you okay screw you phil's 65 all right
screw you
all right
either way
we don't want any piece of john [ __ ]
you're you're on your own
buddy okay
i mean you mean the guy used to smash
his face in the middle linebackers
no i'm not messing with that that's like
that's one of those positions where
really nobody on a football team messes
with the fullback everybody knows he's
the crazy guy in the locker room
everybody knows like he's the one guy
that if you got in a fight with and you
were bashing his face in he would still
be like so what let's keep going so
nobody wants to mess with that guy and i
want no part of john [ __ ] so you're in
deep crap man i'm i mean i'm telling you
we see at least there at least there's
evidence i'm stepping out of the way
for social media there's evidence was
that no more
tweets at each other or anything that
was all he had i don't think he
responded to my
i to my response which was right but but
my second response was this isn't that
complicated he talks to rogers he talks
to the media if he's saying anything
publicly that aaron rodgers doesn't want
him to say he's going to hear from aaron
rodgers or or not hear from aaron
rodgers ever again yeah so
it really does not take a genius which
qualifies me for this assignment to
understand
that rogers is using former teammates
with whom he speaks who will then speak
to the media to get his message out and
the message is he's laying the
foundation to show up and say
hey everybody i'm back yeah what's the
big deal why are all the tv trucks here
wait definitely it looks like he's
laying the foundation for that to go you
know hey
it's fixable i could still come back and
you know you know play football and like
we've talked about a lot he's got no
issues with any players in the locker
room or no coaches on the staff that's
gonna make you know
that's gonna make it easier for him to
walk back and you know hold his head
high or not feel like he was screwed
over in the situation even though he was
but like mike i'm with you 100
you know i mean i might let [ __ ] beat
the crap out of you but i'll sit there
and argue with them that your point was
still right like you're right you know
whether rogers is doing it and you know
yeah maybe manipulating them i would
think really in in my history with these
situations and knowing this that they're
just flat out talking and coons probably
a little bit like hey they want to talk
to me about your situation here and he's
probably texting or calling rogers
telling him that what do you want me to
say what's the message i should convey
that's to me how i would imagine that is
kind of going down there uh but yeah but
i'm i'm with you on the read of
everything else
look at it this way yeah
since this was coon's second media
appearance yes in roughly a week right
if he had said anything the first time
around on cbs sports radio comments that
were picked up and covered by us and
others if he had said anything other
than what aaron rodgers wanted him to
say then there would not have been a
second media appearance hey john do me a
favor just i i appreciate it i love you
but just stay out of it it's kind of
it's it's a delicate time yeah and it
would probably be better if we just
don't do this again you can do all the
media you want just i'd i'd prefer that
you you know if you're going to say that
you've talked to me just say aaron has
asked me politely to not comment on his
situation it's not hard to do
and the fact that kuhn was on nfl
network saying what he said yesterday
tells me that that aaron rodgers fully
aware of what he said last week had no
problem with it and wanted him to say it
again again this is look when you're
going to be smart guy when you're going
to be i got a 35 on the wonderlic bret
what did you get when you're going to be
that guy you get a level of strategy and
sophistication imputed to you regardless
of whether or not it's there but i'm
going to assume that aaron rodgers knows
exactly what he's doing here because
he's a smart guy
yeah i i do i think it's fair with this
i'm not gonna push back on that you know
i do think there's times where we all
look a little too deeply into things he
says but this is not or or things that
are being said or manipulated but this
is one of those that i mean i i don't
think that's the case that yes i think
this is
this has been this has been percolating
in his brain
for over a year since the day jordan
love was drafted so this has been a you
know carefully planned attack throughout
the season he was probably thinking
about it and of course in the off season
he probably took some real time to think
about it so i'm with you there mike
cause you know i love aaron rodgers uh
but this is one i'm i'm with you all the
way
this situation has been on full boil for
most of two weeks now it it dies down
from time to time because there isn't
anything to talk about but two days
after it broke and hijacked the draft
he's in churchill downs talks to mike
tarico tariko wants to put him on camera
he declines that's his chance to say i
don't know what any of this is all about
mike i i don't know where this is coming
from i don't know who's trying to make
me look bad i'm perfectly happy i'm fine
there's no issue instead tarico talks to
him and says on camera there's a chasm
there's a fissure between the team
and aaron rodgers so
also also in this day and age you have
the opportunity anytime you want get the
cell phone device shoot a video put it
on your twitter account i think he's got
over 4 million followers if he wants
anything out there directly
he can do it and he should do it but
it's up to him to decide not to do it
but if you don't do it and you talk to
people like john [ __ ] and james jones
and they speak after speaking to you
we're going to assume that they're
saying what you want him to say yeah
sorry john
sorry john if you didn't realize that's
what your friend was doing if you're a
pawn in his broader game of chess but
that's exactly what's going on yeah i
mean agreed i'm with you all the way i
am i mean i i don't see it any different
way
and listen i don't
i don't sit here and blame rogers for
for what he's doing i really don't
you know i mean again it's a tough
situation we both agree
that he's been kind of screwed
yes
i mean there's no doubt and you know
he's kind of screwed going forward with
the lack of you know the team committing
to him and all of those type of things
so i'm not mad at him for
you know playing these little political
games this way i'm really not you know
it's his life it's his career it's
legacy it's all being affected in a time
where it should not be affected and also
it's you know i just always go back to
yes this is the bed green bay made and
come on
like what
what
what
we all knew aaron rodgers was gonna be
the most bitter sob on the planet when
they did that so how did they not
realize that he was going to be like
this
so it shouldn't be shocking
hey
and you know one last point before we
take a break
as i said last week
rogers has every right to be mad at the
packers for what happened with jordan
love every right packers fans should be
upset with the packers for what they did
last year when they had clear needs that
they didn't address by investing a one
and a four in getting jordan love
but if i'm a packers fan and i really
take a step back and i look at this
objectively number one creating an issue
that required the brain trust to come
see me at least three times when they
had other things to do dropping this
bomb
the first day of the draft and
potentially distracting the gm and the
rest of the front offices they had far
more important work to do over the next
three days the idea that rogers wants
brian goody coons to be fired unrebutted
in any way by aaron rodgers
those are things that i would look at
and then throw on top of it the report
that he was telling teammates last year
who are due to become free agents i may
not be here next year those are things
that i would look at as a packers fan
and say you're undermining the greater
good i understand you're upset but don't
undermine the greater good don't
distract brian gudekunst and his staff
during the draft that's his most
important three days of the year don't
don't ask for him to be fired don't
don't tell teammates you're not going to
be here next year and and wonder whether
or not they're going to run off in free
agency to another team don't distract
the front office when they have free
agency to deal with so that that's my
that's my concern if i'm a packers fan
right and of course pakistan's like
you're just trying to create division no
i'm trying to point out facts i'd be
upset right and if you're not if you
choose not to be upset fine that's your
prerogative but i'd be upset that this
guy has tried to knock my team wobbly at
a critical juncture of the off-season i
know i i listen i try to put myself in
the packers fans shoes a little bit with
this situation you know the thing i just
keep coming back to is like yeah you
might be upset with some of the things
rogers has done here recently but you
know again the the the team got wobbly
from the team i mean it was a
self-inflicted uppercut they threw into
themselves so it's like if i'm a packers
fan i'm a little annoyed with both sides
you know i don't think there's there's
any doubt about that and i probably
would be
you know i'm biased here because i like
rogers too much i'd be more mad probably
at the the packers team there so i don't
know if that's a good honest answer
but here's where rogers is operating on
a higher level than the rest of us
because when he shows up and when he
says everything's fine the media made
too much of it there will be a large
segment of the packers fan base that
swallows the hook
sure and never questions and is just
happy he's back and will gladly join him
in blaming us for making a big deal
about something that was and still is a
big deal he just happens to have decided
to show up and make his money and not
pay back 11.5 million in signing bonus
allocation and another six and 6.8
million in a roster bonuses aren't and
give up 14.7 million in salary
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports